Hello, hello everyone!
Actual rare edited pre-recorded Doki here.
So, today is a very special day.
That's why I'm pre-recorded.
Because I got sponsored by Legacy Steel and Sorcery to check out their game and its early access.
Huge shout-out and thank you to the dev team for reaching out.
It would mean a lot, Dragoons, if you could check out the link in the description below.
Alright, take it away pre-recorded Doki and your bad reaction with no chat to enable you.
I don't know how this is gonna go, not gonna lie.
Oh man, I don't know how it's gonna be like.
Well, first time for everything.
Alright, pre-recorded Doki, it's your turn.
I mean, I'm pre-recorded too, but...
Alright, so I was asked to check out the trailer before I play the game.
And I'm gonna be frank with you guys, I have no idea what this game is about yet.
Because like, you know, the best part is to figure this out as we go along.
So I...
Good job, Doki, you're sponsored!
Anyway...
I mean, I'm like going in blind for things.
Anyway, let's see what this trailer is about, guys.
It's a little weird not having chat to like tell me I'm an idiot.
But it's okay, that's what my inner demons are for.
Oh, it's like an RPG element to it.
Legacy, Steel and...
That's what we're gonna play!
There has to be like different classes and stuff.
Oh, I hope the volume is not too loud.
Thank you, Notorious Studios!
Check out the game in the description!
Oh, shit.
There's like orcs.
If I'm swearing this, thank God my editor is bleeping me out.
Looks like a game where I'm gonna die a lot.
Oh, is this like PvP?
There's PvP in there.
Goodbye!
Wait, I can sleep them?
Oh my God, I can steal your shit!
Harvest resources.
Okay.
Why don't I just choose an auction house and I could bypass the crafting part.
I must again ask for some donations.
Escape with this.
Oh, it's an extraction!
It's a medieval extraction shooter!
Oh, this has to be it, right?
Oh, that's interesting.
I've never seen an extraction shooter but with like bows and swords.
Wait, no, I have.
I guess like this is more like open world-ish because the other one was like in a dungeon.
So this one is more like an open world.
Okay, that's interesting.
I guess we check out the game now.
I'm putting this really close by the way.
This is like it's two hours before the playtest ends.
I'm cutting it real close right now.
Oh, it's an hour and a half till the playtest ends.
Oh, I wanna be the hunter.
The fact that she could stun?
Wait,
actually, I don't know now.
Which one's the stun?
Oh, but then I could be invisible.
I feel like I'm gonna try bow first because it's like a gun but like medieval.
Not jokey.
They'll never know.
They'll never know it's not me.
Play tutorial?
Yes, please.
I think I definitely need the tutorial.
Oh, I have the seed bomb.
This is my seed bomb.
What's three?
What am I doing?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I don't see any cooldowns.
Yeah, I assume it's because like I'm not in the game yet.
So that's why I don't have any cooldowns.
What do I have?
Iron chest?
Uh, better.
Wait, I want this.
Yeah, I got better bow now.
Hello?
Any NPCs for me to kill because I'm in tutorial right now?
I guess I just have to at the top.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, left is dodge.
Oh my gosh, that's a headshot.
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm gonna shoot your leg.
Oh, I should let them...
Okay, now I understand.
Okay, I'm just stupid.
Alright, shoot.
Attack me.
Come on.
Haha!
So predictable.
Oh my god, why are you so tanky though?
I wonder how do I...
I guess I'll just have to drag it for now.
There must be a quick way.
I don't have chat to backstab me.
So this is a very rare opportunity.
I have to actually figure this out myself.
Because I have no chat to backstab me.
No!
Pre-recorded doki.
Why must you suffer?
Oh my god.
And I get bombed?
Oh, if chat was here, they would have stopped me from getting bombed.
Can I take it?
Oh, there we go.
Am I just stupid?
No, okay, now I can have...
Oh, okay, it just bugged out.
Now I can't.
Oh my gosh, thank god chat can't be like, yeah, you are.
Oh, you can't say that.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, what were you gonna do?
I'll never know.
Thank god there's no limited ammo.
I was gonna freak out if there was.
I should actually use my other abilities.
I'm not learning.
Do I actually ever learn?
Hehe.
Open.
Rotate.
Doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
Alright, got my Tetris in.
It's okay, I was seeing it so badly.
Whoa!
Damn goblins!
That's right, I used an ability and I missed.
Oh my god.
Wait, why is he going in the trap?
No!
Oh, no.
Okay, that's right, I have aim at least.
Hahaha!
Despite everything, at least I have A.
How do I... I want to put this in my... in my belt.
I could, right?
I figure I have to put stuff in my belt, though.
Oh, I have a skill tree.
Oh, not Doki, not Doki.
Yep, in the house of not Doki.
This is not Doki.
I'll figure this out.
But does she?
We'll find out later.
Future prerecorded Doki is gonna figure out if she figures this out.
Oh, and then I can get extracted.
She'll figure this out, right, guys?
Guys, I swear I'll figure this out.
Wait, what are the items I got?
Wait, do I not get to keep my items in Tutorial?
No!
That's so... I never got to keep... I never got to keep it in Tutorial!
I'm doing mixed.
I don't want to do this by myself.
I don't want to... All right, let's actually do a real game.
Oh, so there's, like, fireplace.
I get to cook in the fireplace.
Oh, so I can get XP when I'm not playing.
Oh, that's interesting.
Oh my god, there's a critter habitat!
I can tap pets!
That was the best game already.
I get to tap pets.
Oh, I get to make, like, weaponsmith, treasurer.
Oh, the artwork's so... Are these, like, 3D?
I can't tell.
I love the graphics for it, though.
I love the goblin.
He looks like he is a bad person.
I can't say that!
That's prejudice against goblins!
What have they done for us?
What have they done?
Oh my god, that was fast.
Oh, wow, I did not expect that to be really fast.
Oh, man, I hope I have teammates.
That's all I care about.
Wait, is this... Wait, I don't have teammates.
Did I forget to click fill?
No, I don't have teammates.
This is not good for me.
Oh, I forgot.
I must have forgot to press fill, because I know that could be me.
I will not be... What?!
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
That should have dodged.
That's actually so messed up.
Wait, what?
Why did I accidentally use my fire?
Oh, no.
Everything's already not going for Ridoki.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm actually scared, because I... I'm by myself.
Wait, I feel like there's no... There doesn't seem to be, like, anything wrong.
There's no cooldown, so, like, look at my little dance.
Boom.
Get out of there.
This is my high ground.
What's your loot?
Oh, it's over here.
I'm pretty sure there's an easier way to put all of these together.
I'm, like, 100% sure, but, like...
Wait.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God!
Okay, this is not good.
This is not good.
There's way too many people.
There is way... There is way...
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
I am going through a lot right now.
I am going through a lot.
I did not expect 200 skellies right here.
Like, I can't even dance.
Oh, my God!
No!
Oh, no.
Why is there so many of them?
There's a dog!
No!
Where am I?
Okay, okay.
This should be better now.
This should be a lot better now that I'm gonna get a team and they're gonna treat me right.
Wait, we don't fight.
I'll just do... I could just do solo.
Yeah, I don't want... I don't know if matchmaking is gonna be fast or anything.
We're gonna win this one.
I believe.
Can't go wrong this time.
I can't believe.
I got, like...
Everything was out to kill me.
I don't know.
Are you guys good people?
No, they were not good people.
That was...
Oh, okay.
Well, now I know that the...
Okay.
Okay, it's not so bad now.
It's not.
Oh, I forgot to bring heals.
Okay, it's pretty bad.
And I went straight in with...
No, okay.
It's pretty... Guys, it's pretty bad.
You know what?
My mission?
Get to the extraction point.
One golden mine.
It's not that far.
It's 600 meters away.
Alright, thank God I picked Hunter because it's like a gun and, like, I have aim.
Don't mind the fact that I just missed three shots there.
Come on.
Look how tiny his head is.
That's right.
Stand on it.
Oh my God, I'm gaming.
I actually game that so hard.
Where are you going?
It would be a shame if you get trapped.
Alright, now that I know that traps don't do anything to skeletons, I should have known because he's, like, literally a skeleton.
And what's gonna happen?
He just breaks off a piece of his bone.
Alright, here I go.
I'm beelining it.
Wait, is that person?
Oh my God, real person?
Oh my God, real person!
Oh, why are you lagging?!
Hunter!
What the fuck?!
Oh my God!
Bro!
What?!
Oh my God!
Who are you?!
Never mind, maybe Hunter's not it.
What the?!
Okay, now I know Hunter is the warrior who was meta.
Wait, are they friends?
There's no way!
I swear to God, if he doesn't start punching each other...
Oh no, they're fighting each other.
Okay, thank God.
I was gonna be like, are you serious?
There's no way.
You better kill each other.
There's no freaking way.
Okay, this man literally just walked up to me and beat the shit out of me.
Well, now that I know what's meta.
Oh my God, look at them go!
That's right, you deserve to die.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Alright, alright, alright.
We're just gonna head straight to an extraction.
I'm not grabbing any loot, we're just going straight to extraction and then I win.
I call that a moral victory if I could get out of this town.
I'm a thousand kilometers?!
How am I from here to Hawaii?!
Editor, speed this up or speed up until I die.
I'm just running.
Do I still have fall damage or is it okay?
Maybe there is, but I'm just running really fast right now.
I learned, okay?
I learned that, you know, I was so confident.
I was so happy as a hunter.
I was like, oh man, hunter's fun.
It's like I have a gun.
And then I realized, back in the medieval times, being hunter doesn't mean...
Oh my God, I felt like a nerd.
At that point, being put in a locker.
Oh my God, and I'm getting chased right now.
He's gonna get tired, right?
All of these people are gonna get tired, right?
Right, guys?
Right?!
Oh my God, just aggro everything at this point.
I swear to God, if I... Oh, there's guys.
By the way, there's fall damage.
Editor, make sure to include the fact that I broke my ankle.
Oh my God, I made it!
I made it!
Oh my God!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm on HP!
I made it!
Oh my God!
Oh my God, they're all warriors!
What was I doing?!
They're all warriors!
I was so foolish!
We did it!
We won!
We won, everyone!
That's all I've got.
Getting out is a victory in my book.
Oh my God.
Thank you again for Legacy Steel and Stone for sponsoring me today.
To check out their game in early access.
Please, if you wish to support the games, support the devs, and support me, check out the description for the link below to wishlist the game on Steam.
Or maybe check it out if it's already out.
Check out the game too!
So thank you again, everybody!
Pre-recorded Doki signing off, everybody!
Bye!